resterait dans l'histoire monsieur le
président de la république le président
de l'inaction climatique parce qu'au
fond vous êtes un climato arrangeant
vous préféré signer d armistice avec les
lobbys plutôt que de mener la guerre
contre le dérèglement climatique
vous préférez
procrastiner tel mery streep dans le
film don't look up
reporter renoncer
fantasmer sur des solutions dans dix
quinze ou vingt ans
plutôt que de décréter comme nous
voulons faire la mobilisation générale
la mobilisation générale on est tous
d'accord mais la mobilisation générale
c'est un slogan faut ensuite rentrer
dans le détail j'aurais voulu la
mobilisation générale de tous les
européens quand en 2018 la france a
porté un agenda ambitieux de glyphosate
nous avons été peu suivi y compris par
des gouvernements ou les forces
politiques que vous représentez était
aux responsabilités